this is Apple's 16 inch MacBook Pro with
the brand new 5600 M graphics option and
if you guys watched our last two videos
you'll know that there are not only some
massive improvements for things like
graphics rendering but it also performs
incredibly well for gaming like in
fortnight and call of duty warzone so if
you guys haven't seen those videos we'll
link to both of them in the end screen
at the end of this video but for this
one we're gonna answer a question that a
lot of you guys have been asking in the
comments section how does this new 5600
M graphics chip compare to an e GPU so
we're gonna do just that now before we
get into it I want to mention that we
have our new premium all over Apple
product design t-shirt for sale in the
merch shelf below this video so thank
you guys for supporting us for our a GPU
system we chose the Razer core X
enclosure for $300 but there's also the
chroma Edition which features RGB
lighting and extra ports like a couple
of USB ports for peripherals and an
Ethernet port as for the graphics card
itself
we chose the AMD 5700 XT since it's
proven itself as the best overall choice
in 2020 so the total for the EGP you
comes out to around 680 or 780 dollars
if you chose the chroma enclosure as for
the mac books
we're gonna compare three different
systems the new 5600 M MacBook Pro by
itself which is almost fully loaded the
base 16 inch MacBook Pro hooked up to
the e GPU and the 20 2013 inch MacBook
Pro with the 10th gen hooked up to the
Egypt and they're all updated to Mac OS
10 point 15 point 5 and Final Cut Pro 10
point 4 point 8 and by the way some of
these systems are on sale so we'll link
to them down in the description as well
as the e GPU components that we
recommend
now with the e GPU setup keep in mind
that you want to be using it with an
external display to get the full power
out of it so let's start with comparing
the raw graphics performance using
Geekbench 5s metal test for some reason
the fifth
xte GPU is scoring very low compared to
the 5600 M which scored about 43,000
points we realized that there was some
issues with the drivers so we had to
hook up a second display to the a GPU to
get the full power now quite a bit
higher than the 5600 M and by the way
protip if you don't want to use two
displays you can use the link below to
buy an HDMI dummy adapter which tricks
the system into thinking it's a display
thus giving you the better performance
but even with that the 5700 XT is still
not scoring as high as it would if it
wasn't a desktop PC and that's because
of the fact that it's an eg PU and it's
sending all of that data through a
single Thunderbolt 3 cable so the lower
performance is understandable now moving
on to the unit in heaven gaming test the
5600 M MacBook Pro by itself
surprisingly outperformed the e GPU
setups even though it scored lower in
Geekbench 5 which is probably because
heaven uses OpenGL instead of metal we
then tested GFX bench 5.0 which actually
uses metal and in the Aztec ruins test
the e GPU system was around 40% faster
than the 5600 M MacBook Pro and in the
Manhattan test there was an even bigger
difference so it's crazy to see this
performance jump compared to the heaven
test now before we get into comparing
actual gaming performance let's do some
Final Cut Pro 10 video editing tests and
most of these are heavily graphics
dependent so the difference is in CPUs
won't really affect the results as much
as other tests do starting with the
Bruce X benchmark which is almost purely
graphics dependent we can see that the
5600 M is performing incredibly well and
the EGP you setups are taking quite a
bit longer which is interesting because
we've seen better results in the past
but maybe the e GPU performance slowed
down with the new versions of Mac OS or
Final Cut Pro next up in our one minute
HEV C stabilization test the 5600 M
destroyed the other two once again with
the 13-inch falling way behind now in
the thirty second cannon c200 Ross
stabilization test the difference was
even larger between all three so the
5600 M is really proving itself so far
we then decided to run some export tests
just to see the difference in export
speeds and the base 16-inch with the e
GPU was closer to the 5600 M in our 4 K
export test but not close enough what's
even more interesting is that the base
16 inch MacBook Pro by itself was faster
than when connected to the e GPU and
that's because of the Thunderbolt 3
cable bottleneck basically the data has
to go from the CPU to the GPU and then
back to the CPU when you're exporting so
that's why it's taking longer now
finally in our very tough 4.5 K red raw
export test the 5600 M was the fastest
with the 13-inch MacBook Pro in the e
GPU taking way longer because of CPU
limitations so we can see that in each
in every Final Cut Pro 10 test the 5600
M outperformed the e GPU systems and
sometimes by far now let's get into some
video games starting with League of
Legends on Mac OS we maxed out all of
the settings and set the resolution to
around 1440 P full screen on each
machine we were surprised to see that
the 5600 M 16 inch MacBook Pro
outperformed the e GPU by an average of
around 40 fps however the fans were
definitely louder
since the e GPU has the advantage of
being outside of the MacBook Pro with a
much better cooling system we then moved
on to four night in mac OS and set the
resolution to around 1080p full screen
on each machine and then set the
graphics quality to high but at a
hundred percent render resolution one
weird thing we noticed while playing
with the each view systems was that the
frame rates weren't very consistent with
the minimum fps dipping lower than
expected but on the flip side the 5600 M
MacBook Pro by itself offered very
consistent
frame rates which led to a much more
pleasant gaming experience and on top of
that it played at an average of around
30 to 40 FPS higher so from all of those
tests not only does the 5600 M
completely destroy the e GPU with either
the 13 inch or 16 inch MacBook Pro and
Final Cut Pro video editing but it's
also much better at gaming with higher
fps and more consistent FPS as well
now the 5600 M is definitely more
expensive but this shows us that it's
definitely worth the investment and it's
a much better choice compared to getting
an HP u for both productivity work and
if you want to do some gaming on the
side so I think it's great that you no
longer have to buy a macbook pro for
productivity work and then buy a
separate gaming pc or gaming laptop if
you want to do some gaming just by the
150 600m macbook pro and it does
everything you need and no matter
whether you choose to go with an e GPU
or the 5600 M MacBook Pro we'll have
links to the best deals on all of these
Mac books and they each of you parts
down in the description below so
hopefully this video helped you out and
if it did go ahead and click the
subscribe button above for our WWDC
coverage on Monday and if you like this
t-shirt go ahead and check it out in the
description below or the merch shelf and
definitely go and watch those two videos
that I mentioned earlier in this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]